spring and kirk kerb street of course
espn college football analyst
game day is at louisville this weekend
ahead of abc saturday night football
number 17 miami at number 18 louisville
kirk will be on the call with chris
fowler and allison williams herbie good
morning thanks for joining us uh what do
you make of what's happening in the big
ten
um huge obviously i mean we've we've
been talking about
the big ten and the pac-12 for for
several weeks pac-12 was really never in
play but the big ten over the last
couple weeks it's been gaining traction
they had big meetings over the weekend
and
a lot of people thought there was a real
chance that the presidents might take a
look at some of the new data and
some of the new testing protocols and
maybe green light this
and it's official now and it's big i
mean it's it's
it's big for college football to be able
to include the big ten with the start
date of the 24th it gets
them in this their championship game
will end the same weekend that this
college football playoff committee will
be able to
select their four teams and uh with that
start date if everything goes okay
as go goes as planned that will allow
them to still be involved in the
playoffs so you get now the big
ten back into the mix with the other
conferences the big 12 sec and htc so
the only conference you leave out is
is the pac-12 so that's that's huge and
and hopefully everything goes well
and these players stay healthy what
would have been the long-term effect you
think on
the big ten if they didn't play i don't
know if they were there would have been
necessarily i've been asked that
a lot you know boy this is really going
to hurt them in recruiting
um i don't know if it hurts the blue
bloods you know
if they would not have been able to play
penn state ohio state michigan
they're still going to be able to
recruit it at a certain level and get
great players as long as you're
producing players that go to the nfl
you're going to recruit so i think it
would it would
hurt it would have been a tough year to
endure and sit around i think it's been
a tough couple weeks to be honest with
you
for these players and coaches to sit
around and watch other people play
football
and for them not to be able to play
football and so that that would have
been hard to watch an entire year and be
left out but i don't know
dan if it would have had necessarily
long-term ramifications in any way
do you think the pac-12 is regretting
this decision
like you know are they scrambling the
jets here to go wait a minute if the big
tent
because the big ten and pac-12 they're
joined at the hip here
and if the big 10 is going all in and i
know there are some state
issues there in the pac-12 but does the
pac-12 try to resuscitate this or maybe
just
fold up the tents and try you know for
spring
yeah you know larry scott their
commissioner came out
you know a week ago and said you know
the the the new
testing that's going to be readily
available soon out out west
the quote was it's a game changer for
them as well as far as being able to get
and find out more about who's
who's uh affected by this virus and who
is not
but you talked to david shaw you talked
to chip kelly you talked to clay helton
they would tell you forget about playing
games we can't even go to the practice
you know we can't even go to the
facility right now so there are so many
restrictions
on some of these universities i don't
honestly i don't even think these
coaches
are up in arms at this point i don't
think that they're they're beating down
the door of larry scott and saying this
is unfair
the way we felt that from the big ten i
mean from jim harbaugh to ryan day
to scott frost to james franklin i mean
these coaches were adamant
about we need to play how can middle
school football play in our state how
can high school football be
played in our state how can professional
football being played in our state
and we're sitting down not playing like
that's that's what's going on in the big
ten footprint
whereas out west you know i don't think
i feel that same kind of energy
of frustration i think at some point
they're going to get started but you
talk about being left out
uh and and playing you know what would
be considered irrelevant football
uh the pac-12 is really on the outside
looking in and
it's a conference that candidly has been
struggling to
to matter uh without usc without
ucla really the oregon brand is about
the only one right now carrying the day
before covet for the pac-12 when it
comes to the college football playoff
washington
had it going there for a little bit with
chris peterson but they they have really
struggled
to continue to matter um you know in the
on the landscape of this sport and so
now to have this happen to them
big time setback for that conference how
many big ten teams do you think have a
legitimate chance
of qualifying for the final four uh i
would say ohio state could be
depending they had a couple players opt
out i i don't know the rules i think
they can opt back in um
if they decide to do that wyatt davis
one of the best offensive linemen in the
country and sean wade is probably the
top corner
in the country they've opted out i don't
know if they've signed with an agent i
don't know what's happening there but if
they come back
i think sean wade is scheduled to sign
with an agent this morning
so the timing of this you know that yeah
i think you could opt back in
but i don't know if you can if you sign
in yeah if you sign with an agent it's a
it's that would be a done deal but
i i would look at that if before all of
this if you and i were just talking who
are the teams to beat it would have been
ohio state and clemson
you got justin fields you and i've
talked about and trevor lawrence who
everybody's talked about
uh those would be the two teams that
people would have said are going to meet
in the national championship
with alabama and georgia and teams like
that being out there as well
i would throw penn state um james
franklin i think is elevated to that
program where they always have a chance
to be competitive in the big ten
and i think michigan with jim harbaugh i
know he gets ridiculed a lot for not
being able to live up to what the
expectations were
but i i think you know the way they
recruit the athletes they have
they got a different quarterback this
year which will be interesting
so i think those three teams um and you
know as an outsider i would always throw
wisconsin
people don't nationally probably respect
them the way they should but uh
wisconsin's always going to be a tough
out as well coming out of the big ten
west
there's always this talk of you know the
next college coach who goes to the nfl
and dabo sweeney's name is kind of there
and i know your sons go to clemson but
could you see dabo sweeney let's say
jacksonville had the number one pick and
they could take trevor lawrence
could you see dabo sweeney leaving
clemson to take over jacksonville
no i i i just don't see it um
he if there's ever been a guy that's
made for college football
it it would be it would be dabo sweeney
um
and and the other thing is the the the
the power and control that you have
as a head coach at alabama or clemson or
ohio state or some of these places
and then to go to the nfl i i think it's
a little bit different you know where
you're very rarely are you the gm
and the head coach and so because of
that i
and i just know the personality of daba
i think he'd really have a
a difficult time in the nfl with some of
the stuff that he does that would be
considered maybe
unorthodox or quote unquote almost corny
in the nfl world
in college it's it works it fits with 18
to 21 22 year old kids so
no i i don't think he'll ever leave i'd
be shocked i shouldn't say ever but i'd
be shocked if he ever went to the nfl
you're out in your neighborhood here are
the neighbors looking at you like
what is kirk doing outside no
no no one's out here right now oh okay
because it looks like you're
you're talking to yourself like you know
do you have the best arm in the
neighborhood
uh i think i do okay having four boys
stayed active throwing the football did
you hear about the fowler appearance
he was jacked tight shirt
he's ripped fowler are you kidding me
fowler's going at about four percent
body fat these days and
yoked up no do not take him on in an arm
wrestling you you have no
shot no he said i'm 58 and i'm jacked
and i go
hey i'm not going to argue with you no
and he's not he's not afraid to wear
that that's small
it was fun monday night i hope you
enjoyed it and uh
i know that you know when we were
talking to some people who try to make
that change for one game they're like
i don't know what the college football
rules are fowler is saying
you know college to the nfl i you know
there's so many of these rules that are
different from college football was it
tough for you
yeah i mean i visited with john perry
who helps us out at espn who's a former
nfl referee
and you know there is a change from
from one level to the next
i was hoping john was on call for us so
if we did have any
controversial calls or anything like
that he would be there to kind of pick
up the pieces and help us out so i was
definitely going to rely on him
but um man i just had so much fun i was
really surprised
that i had as much fun you know there
weren't any fans in the stadium
but we had great story lines you know we
had we had ben coming back
and how would he look and we had juju
smith schuster who's you know a big name
who's trying to bounce back from from
where they were a year ago where he
was offensively without ben he had the
steelers defense it's one of the best in
the league and then yeah the giants with
joe judge and daniel jones and saquon
barkley and
he's trying to change the culture so i
had an absolute ball i was shocked how
quick the game moves in comparison to
college like the quarters just
man they fly by but man all everything
considered it was
an absolute ball and i love working with
chris obviously
it was good listen uh have fun this
weekend louisville number 18
miami number 17 college game day in
louisville this weekend and uh kirk will
be doing the game with chris fowler
allison williams
good to talk to you herbie safe travels
you too dan take care bud